stoke on trent a key brick in the
conservative red wall this city now at
the heart of the leveling up agenda
awarded more regeneration cash from
government than any other local
authority but also a place feeling the
pinch one of the hardest hit when it
comes to fuel poverty
money here matters westminster far away
but the government promising change in
streets like this we need to get this
country moving at top speed again we
need faster growth from celebrating
ceramics and stoke to supporting pride
in british history in bishop auckland
these old ceramic works in stoke the
potters are long gone but their heritage
lives on the chancellor here just weeks
ago pledging six million pounds to
rebuild this site factory floor space
being turned into flats helping to boost
local business owners like joe and chris
the money is here we see action from it
so that money is invested correctly into
the bricks and mortar there's a lot of
talking there's a lot of activity around
people saying things but this city
really does hinge itself upon
things happening but are you minded to
kind of
back this government this the
conservative party into the next
election this is the real testing point
for the comfort for the government
really to start delivering
start understanding that manifesto and
get back to some of the basics of it
and i feel that that is what my vote
would personally be on leveling up for
me is really
it's something you can't judge in one
breath at this point in time i'd like to
really
judge it in maybe 10 20 30 years time
but for so many voters they're judging
right now do you have faith in boris
johnson you can do it that he will
deliver i think he's fur coat and no
knickers sort of guy i think he's the
thought who goes says all these things
like most politicians and doesn't
deliver
from superfast broadband to better
transport links levelling up a big
bucket of possibilities for people here
getting better healthcare
getting access to things bus services
are awful where i am what does leveling
up mean to you i don't think anybody
knows to be quite honest and i'm looking
at the news on the television and
everybody says oh yeah it seems a good
idea that's leveling up but nobody
thinks nobody's quite sure what it means
if get brexit done helped win places
like stoke on trent for boris johnson's
conservatives in 2019 leveling up was
designed to secure those gains it was
the prime minister's national mission to
lift up poorer parts of the country but
ask people here and they don't really
understand what leveling up actually
means and the government are running out
of time to show them before the next
election
but ministers clear too that this
leveling up plan won't be delivered
until the end of the decade and in the
meantime people here are facing a cost
of living crisis right now beth rigby
sky news stoke on trent
you